[Music]
I get asked a lot about the state of
capitalism and I think that for those
members of society of a certain age we
think of capitalism as being locked in
an ideological battle with socialism
perhaps or even communism but we never
really saw the capitalism might be
defeated by its own child technology and
I think that what we find is that even
the most die-hard free-market economists
usually safe place for what they call
market failure that is markets really
only work when the value of something in
the price of that object or service
coincide so the key question is what
causes value in price to get out of
alignment and in fact every government
on earth as a form of levying taxes of
some form because at some levels there
are certain things that need to be paid
for that cannot in fact be priced where
they must be valued so for example
raising a standing army is tough because
if somebody chooses not to pay for it
it's very difficult to exclude them from
the protection of that army so that in
general what we find is that these
market failures are found in every
economy but they are also hopefully a
small portion of the economic activity
so that we can deal with them as a
special educate the problem with this
because the technology appears to do
something about figuring out the size of
that small slice and making it rather
large so for example if I record a piece
of music once upon a time if you wanted
a high quality version of that music you
had to go to the folks who actually
press the record albums but now I can
record music with arbitrary fidelity and
share it as a small file and my having a
copy of that file doesn't preclude
anyone else from copying the file and
using it themselves there's no question
that the number of times I use that file
doesn't really degrade
the file because it's in fact digital so
in that situation musicians were among
the first to feel the earth crumbled
beneath their feet and they had to find
new business models because in fact they
found that they had gone from producing
a private good where price and value
coincided to producing a public good and
the idea of taxing people to pay for
both an army and their diet of jazz and
rock and roll probably didn't make a lot
of sense so the danger is is that more
and more things are being turned into
small files and that means that the
portion of the pie that is private goods
is likely to shrink this is one of
several different forces another one
that I talked about in an essay called
anthropic capitalism is that software
has some very peculiar features
traditionally technology has moved us
from low value occupations into higher
value occupation' so well we always
decry the loss of jobs we usually create
new jobs which are more fulfilling and
less taxing and therefore those who've
cried wolf when they've seen technology
laying waste to the previous occupations
those people have usually just been
wrong the problem with software is that
software spends most of its time in
loops almost all code can be broken into
two kinds of code code that runs once
and never repeats and code that loops
over and over and over
unfortunately what jobs are is usually
some form of a loop where somebody goes
to work and does some version of
whatever it is they've been trained to
do every day now the danger of that is
is that what we didn't realize is that
our technical training for occupations
maneuvers the entire population into the
crosshairs of software and not just a
question it's not just a question in
this case of being moved from lower
value repetitive behaviors and the
higher ones but the problem is is that
all repetitive behaviors are in the
crosshairs
or so it's not that there's nowhere to
go we still have the Rube Goldberg
sections of code where something will
happen only once you know a company will
be founded never to be repeated a poem
will be composed it won't will never
need to be recomposed but the problem
here is is that most people don't see
themselves as opportunists in this
positive sense right they don't see
themselves as capable of doing these
one-off acts of inspiration which will
probably always be fairly highly
rewarded they see themselves as needing
a repetitive behavior on which they can
build their families their hopes and
their dreams and in general that may be
coming to a close even if that's always
been false in the past I think that
there's excellent reason to think that
the era may have changed when we lost
the ability to beat computers at chess
we immediately thought of go as being a
deeper game but that bought us a very
small respite from the power of the
computer and I don't even know of anyone
searching for new games more
human-friendly than go to maintain our
edge so I think it's really important to
understand that where we are is that we
may need a hybrid model in the future
which is paradoxically more capitalistic
than our capitalism of today and perhaps
even more socialistic than our communism
of yesteryear because so many souls will
require respect and hope and freedom and
choice who may not be able to defend
themselves in the market as our machines
and our software gets better and better
and this is one of the reasons why
something like universal basic income
comes out of a place fiercely
capitalistic like Silicon Valley because
despite the fact that many view the
technologists
mercenary megalomaniacs in fact these
are the folks who are closest to seeing
the destruction that their work may
visit upon the population and I don't
know I think of any nine ten or eleven
figure individual at the moment that I'm
familiar with
who isn't worrying about what we're
going to do to take care of those who
may not be able to meet their
expectations with training and jobs as
in previous models whether it's you know
truck and car driving is one of the
largest employers of working-age men
threatened by self-driving vehicles or
any of the other examples for example
computers that are capable of writing
sports stories from the scores alone so
in all of these cases I think the
technology is actually forcing those who
are most familiar with it to become most
compassionate and whether or not we are
going to leaven our capitalism with some
communism or start from some sort of
socialist ideal and realize that if we
don't find a way to grow our pie very
aggressively with the tiny number of
individuals who are capable of taking
over operations of great complexity I
think that we are going to have some
kind of a hybrid system I wish I could
tell you what it was going to look like
but the fact is nobody knows universal
basic income is very interesting but is
clearly a first step and I would say
really a first draft of a part of a
theory that we just don't have yet
honestly I'm rather confused about
whether to be optimistic or pessimistic
one of the things I find most perplexing
is that our government is still
populated by people who come from sort
of softer disciplines if you will
whether that's law whether these people
come from poli-sci very few people in
government come from a hardcore
technical background there are very few
senators who could solve a partial
differential equation or representatives
who could program
computer and I think that this is really
a terrible inversion of what should be
happening as the world becomes more
technically demanding it's important
that the children of engineers
mathematicians and scientists grow up
with the children of politicians or
executives and what we've seen is we've
seen this terrible economic
stratification where the technical
professions were turned into support
roles for this different leadership
class now during the 50s for example we
would have university presidents who
might come from a physics background
such as we had at the University of
Pennsylvania the atomic bomb came out of
World War two as did radar we came to
understand the incredible power of
computers like any AK and during that
period of time there was a tremendous
vogue for thinking of a technical
intellectual elite that could in fact
lead us into a more hopeful and
technological scientific tomorrow
somewhere along the line that got lost
and I'm very concerned that we have the
technical talent to build an optimistic
future but for whatever reason we're so
terrified now of those technical folks
that we keep attempting to subordinate
them to keep them on a leash to make
sure that they are not the ones in the
know with power with decision-making
abilities and I think that if you look
at a society like China's China
certainly not falling for this trap and
they are proceeding along a very
different path so I think whether or not
we understand where we are and we make
the correct decisions for the optimistic
future depends as to whether we have the
right leadership class do we view our
technical people as support staff for
the true decision-makers or do we
realize that in fact these are the
people who should have been making the
decisions all along I think
you think about for example the
Challenger disaster it was the
management class that didn't understand
the real risks the engineers knew just
how much risk was being taken and I
think that in fact if we could just
invert that relationship we'd have a
much better chance at an optimistic
outcome
[Music]